you're working hard you got this new
show on ABC it starts on the Super Bowl
day which is not too much pressure yeah
what's the show called Jimmy Kimmel show
Jimmy Kimmel Live Jimmy Kimmel Live and
what is the studio called it's really
it's really embarr the whole thing is
embarrassing all the mail says my name
on it so I think everything's for me and
so I walk by like somebody's desk and I
take things I start opening like what
are you doing with my mail and I
realized Jimmy on everything you are a
show now for the they built you a
theater like like the Ed theater they
rebuilt the Chevy Chase Theater they
they built you a theater at the
elcapitan theater they remodeled a
portion of it have they told you like
any kind of time period they're looking
for some they told me I have to have it
together in uh in two and a half weeks
or else I'm out no they didn't they're
in it for you know and listen I've heard
this everywhere I've ever worked is
we're you know we're not looking right
off the bat you don't have to do well
we're looking to grow something for
years we're looking to sure they that's
what they told Chevy Chase trust me
they're not looking to grow any well
that's what their bosses are telling
them too so yeah but I think I have to
do well fairly quickly when it says
Jimmy Kimmel Live is it a live show yeah
it's live oh really yeah wow no kidding
and mistakes and everything oh yeah and
we did a couple tou shows and there are
a lot of them what like what like what
happens every single time um they come
to me I'm looking the wrong way oh good
so the guests are coming out on either
side and I don't know what's happening I
I'm looking I'm really I'm really not
good at it it turns out I really at the
end of the of the first show I was just
like this is not going to work this
really is work felt like I was
pretending to be a talk show host and no
one wants to be on my show either oh
really I was going to say are you having
trouble booking people cuz what do you
tell them yeah like who did you get for
your test shows well the Test shows I
was able to land Adam Corolla wow how
depressing and Ben Stein oh my goodness
oh God I mean you know what how is Ben
Stein my Uncle Frank was on the no
seriously who who who is your your Uncle
Frank who's your first guest on the
super bow we don't have one you don't
even have a guest oh the we had to turn
in um like a schedule to TV God it has
to go like 3 weeks and we have no I mean
we have no guest nothing to give them so
we uh I just surprise guest with an
exclamation point under every show any
indication that Letterman or Leno are
the least bit aggravated that you're
coming on ABC I'm on Letterman tonight
so he's uh he's all right with it I
guess and that's insulting too Leno uh
yeah Leno does not like me that much are
you nervous as hell I'm nervous yeah I'm
always nervous though but uh yeah I'm
I'm I'm pretty nervous are you gonna
have a band you got a band leader I got
a band the band is my uh my buddy I've
he's been my best friend since I was 9
years old who is that his name is ceto
escobido he's uh he grew up across the
street for me him and his dad and it's a
very I have a lot of family members
working on the show my Uncle Frank my
cousin s my cousin Mickey it's a that's
a good idea Family Affair yeah otherwise
you never get to see anybody I mean you
really don't yourself a nonprofessional
it's good I like that so you're nervous
yes it's a big step for you I wish you
luck I think you're in a safe time slot
1205 you do well great you're a hero if
you do the same nobody cares what's on
there now they just have filler in there
now like an interview show I should call
it filler I'm sure somebody will get
furious but it's just a temporary show
watch I think you're funny well thanks I
just sit there and you know and do your
thing don't who cares yeah well it's
it's all I can do it's not like I have a
whole host of talents I can go to like
tonight I'm going to sing right there's
not going to be any of that on the show
I wish you a lot of luck dude I mean I
really do I think you're a funny
talented guy but things can go horribly
wrong I know they can can and
will